Greetings Ines!
Hello. Welcome.
Hi, Daniel. Thank you. Yes,
well, we're really looking
forward to your presentation. You can
share your slides and go for it.
Great.
It can you see it?
Yes. Looks great. Thank you. All right,
good. So thank you so much for having
me. I'm really happy to present this
paper today, and particularly because
it's the very first time that I present
this work. So I'm really looking forward
to any feedback and
any reactions to this work.
OK, so the aim of this paper was to
apply the free energy principle to
analyze the interdependent dynamics
between living systems on the one hand,
and nonliving planetary processes.
And this, hopefully, would, we hope,
allow us to gain some insights into the
future states of Gaia. And by Gaia we're
going to mean the Earth and formulate
some predictions and devise potential
interventions to alleviate future
dysfunction on the planet.
Okay? So then the lineup for the
presentation is I'm first going to go
over, in brief, the theory,
the concept of Gaia, so known as the
Gaia hypothesis. Then I'm going
to go into just giving some essentials
on the free energy principle, which I'm
assuming that it's not really necessary,
but just for the sake of the flow of my
argument. Then I'm just going to present
some things on the free energy principle
and specifically on self organizing
interacting systems. And then I'm going
to apply the free energy principle to
the Gaia poses is in a sort of like
comparison analysis, as in how do they,
if at all, complement each other for
epistemic gain? And then after
having done that, this should be should
allow us to inform or to gain some
insights as per the human behavior in
relation to Gaia or the planet Earth.
Okay, so let's see how it goes. So first
I want to introduce the notion of
biophilia, which plays a fundamental
role in this work. So biophilia
came first, or came more prominently
in this particular book here, and it's
quite interesting. The idea is that the
relation of humanity to the rest of the
natural world is essentially one of
dependence. And this is very much
already in the literature and the free
energy principle. But more than that,
there is this view of the necessity of a
continued survival and flourishing that
is utterly contingent upon the state and
functioning of the environment. So we're
talking about things like very
utilitarian things like survival,
flourishing, mental health, right? So
individuals interact with the
environment. So to achieve that,
but then on top of that, we wanted to
add another conceptual layer which is or
concerns how humans possess an
innate cognitive disposition towards
nature, which is known and developed in
this particular other field of work as
biophilia. And this is the idea of
the natural psychological disposition of
humans to seek out and connect with
other living organisms and the natural
environment. So that's kind of like the
idea that is encapsulated in the whole
framework and theory under biophilia.
So then this seems to if
that's the case of as things are
described by biophilia, then that seems
to bring us to a dilemma.
On the one hand, we have these natural
tendencies, so to speak, of humans to
engage with the natural world in a
very positive and constructive way. And
on the other hand we see the lack of
action to protect the Earth. And here we
have in mind particularly the case of
the climate crisis. So in the
presentation I'm going to make my way
slowly towards getting to that and to
better understand the dilemma.
Okay? So let's go in brief over the Gaia
hypotheses. So this is a concept
that comes more prominently in James
Loflock's book Gaia a New Look
at Life on Earth. And the idea there
is that 3.8 billion years that
life has persisted on Earth and
conditions have remained remarkably
constant and favorable across a huge
range of parameters. The Gaia hypothesis
is that this consistency or constancy is
a natural product of evolution.
In a modification, however, of the
canonical Darwinism, the Gaia hypothesis
somewhat modifies canonical Darwinism
how? Well, by thinking that rather than
evolution of the individual organisms on
an inert environment, what evolves
is the whole Earth system with its
living and nonliving parts existing as
a tight coupled entity. So this is the
kind of like, so to speak, refreshing or
new way of thinking that somewhat
reformulated a little bit of Darwinism,
right? The emphasis is not how one
individual organism evolves or
species evolves, but the whole Earth as
a system. So that's quite interesting
because, for example,
the view that the combined genetic
wealth of information of the whole
system becomes much more prominent here
than the Darwinistic kind of view and
this acquires characteristics that are
conductive to its continued existence
and in turn affect changes on the
environment. So then,
seen as a whole organism or as a whole
system, one can look at Gaia or the
Earth as a complex system which appears
to have the goal of regulating the
climate and the chemistry at a
comfortable state of life. And these
views and these ideas have come to gain
more official expression in 2001
with the Amsterdam Declaration on Earth
system science precisely endorsing this
view on the planet Earth as a whole
system. So then the Gaia hypothesis
is a complex system in various ways
because it changes in
an adaptive and nonlinear way.
It also displays dynamical emergent
and sudden tipping behavior. And when
bifurcation points are reached, the new
tractor states form, new tractor states
are formed. And this means that it also
self organizes and there is
interdependence between the processors
of the system. And finally,
the Gaia hypothesis seems to be quite
interesting and extraordinary in the
sense that it brings together so many
different fields such as ecology,
climate science, cybernetics, complex
systems theory, chaos, mathematics and
philosophy of mine and that's just a
few. All right. So then
the idea is of the Gaia hypothesis is
that we could look at the planet from
orbit or as it is known, the overview
effect. And the Gaia hypothesis offers
this glimpse of a fundamentally
different way of thinking of the planet,
of thinking that in fact dominated
mostly by human history. So it's a
little bit of like that very inspiring
clip by Karl Sagan, the Pale blue
dot whereby the world is
considered. So throughout the human
history there's typically a tendency for
the world or the planet to be considered
from a single living organism,
though, rather than an it. So that's the
idea of overview effect and taking this
overview effect to look at the planet as
this whole living system rather than an
it. Okay? So then we can think
about the Gaia hypotheses as like
Newtonian physics or even as the free
energy principle. The Gaia hypotheses
can be seen much more as a framework or
a method of investigation rather than a
falsifiable empirical claim.
So in this sense, these particular
frameworks, they are and should be
judged by their usefulness and not
by their purported correctness with
usefulness. Importantly, usefulness is
to be determined by factors such as
parsimony, coherence and consistency
plus its empirical and epistemic
power to explain phenomena, produce new
facts and so on in a given context and
at a given time frame. So that's the
stance that we think that should be
taken on the Gaia hypothesis. All right?
So now having said a few words on the
Gaia hypothesis now I'm going to just
prepare the stage by saying a few words
on the Fiang principle which, given the
topic of this conference, needs no
introduction. But for these purposes I
must mention just a few things. So the
Fiang principle, we take it to be the
case as well that it is a methodology to
understand overserved patterns of
behavior sorry, observed patterns of
behavior in the natural world. So then
we apply the free energy principle as
the tool and methodology to analyze
these interdependent dynamics between
living systems and planetary processes,
right? Kind of like these goggles,
these methodological, technical,
scientific goggles that you put on to
gain insights into the future states of
Gaia or the Earth such as to make
future formulate predictions and devise
potential interventions in this
particular case with the care of
alleviating future potential or present
dysfunction.
Okay, so the free energy principle very
much aligns with this thinking
by Ewan Schwellinger and the view
that the second law of thermodynamics or
under the second law of thermodynamics
that open systems like us should
tend to dissipation.
However interestingly, there are
displays of this super cool thing,
the negantropy, which are pockets of the
universe where order and bodily
integrity are maintained in the face of
the surge towards chaos or towards
entropy or towards dissipation. And this
view of the pockets of the universe is
incredibly interesting because this is
where we find self organizing systems
like us. And what is so peculiar that
distinguishes these self organizing
living systems from nonliving systems is
that they have the capacity of acting
upon and exchanging matter,
energy or information with the
environment in order to seemingly defy
the second law and therefore or thereby
avoid dissipation and chaos
and entropy. So that's extraordinary.
So then active inference becomes this
very useful tool to tell us or to
explain elucidate how these
systems seemingly defy the second law,
how they resist entropy, how the
self organizing systems combat entropy
through the interaction, maintaining
their integrity via homeostasis.
So then they maintain this energetic
integrity. They utilize energy to stay
within a specific range of states that
is vital for their survival and
preserving their existence. And they
also engage with these feedback cycles
which are the feedback actions like
drinking when thirsty or moving away
from heat signify working, accomplished
by bound energy, contrasting with the
free energy. They also define the
thermodynamics, as I just mentioned, by
seemingly challenging the law, they
minimize entropy and safeguard their
free energy. And finally this
behavior that we observe in these self
organizing living systems in
striving to minimize free energy is
or agrees with a certain principle
that we know, which is the free energy
principle. Okay? So then,
as I said earlier and as we know but
just to keep in mind then active
inference becomes a very useful tool to
understand and make predictions about
these coupling dynamics taking place
between interacting systems, living
systems. Internal states is both
operationally closed and
thermodynamically open to the external
states creating this distinct boundary
which we usually mathematically capture
with Markov blanket. And then this
interaction unfolds through the
immediate of active and sensory
states. Then the key point here to
keep in mind is that what we want to
have for adaptation and well being is
that there is a balanced interaction
between sensory and active states. And
this is because it is within the
interaction between sensory and active
states that so to speak, all of the
important things happen in order for the
system to be well adjusted attuned
adapted to the environment.
So living systems avoid this
dissipation. They want to remain alive,
they do everything in their power, they
navigate their environments in order to
avoid this dissipation which is also or
can be also said to minimize free
energy. And they avoid their dissipation
by doing either one of the two things
either by changing the model or changing
the world, by acting upon the world.
And this is extremely crucial for the
point that I want to make later on.
So now I want to apply the Fionergy
principle to the Guy hypothesis and see
how that comes together in
identifying and developing and why do I
want to do that? I want to do that
because I've also already mentioned it.
But I'm just going to refresh it because
I want to identify and develop
interventions to rectify any potential
maladaptive responses, namely actions
which are antithetical to maintaining
the integrity of the system. What we
want is to have healthy, well adjusted
adaptive systems and human behavior
particularly that leads to
the imbalance within the Markov blanket
states, is or could be considered
sometimes maladaptive or pathological.
And this will be the last point I'm
going to make in the presentation, but
for now want to focus on how does
the French principle deal with the Gaia
hypothesis as a
self organizing system like Ruth? Just
saying. The Gaia meets the requirements
to be formalized as part of an active
inference system. It exists in a non
equilibrium steady state, which means
that its processes and states must
persist over time within a range of
states that are far from equilibrium.
That means resisting entropy. And the
Gaia is also distinguishable from its
largest scale cosmic environment such as
other planets and the rest of the
universe. It is also defined
by the conditional independence that we
were just talking about between the
internal and external stage which
influence each other only vicariously.
So then we can taking that into
consideration, we can even see that some
of the people have already done this
kind of like line of reasoning, they've
already run it through and they did that
by employing Markov blanket to analyze
the Earth's climate system dynamics,
which is quite interesting. What they
did was they looked at metabolic rates
of the biosphere and they represented
them as internal states and space
weather as external states and then they
looked at active states as mirrored
greenhouse effect shifts and sensory
states as echoed ocean driven
temperature changes and then internal
and external states. The idea here is
that they indirectly influenced each
other through ocean's delayed response.
Then Earth's climate is interpreted as
anticipatory minimizing variational,
free energy. So we take this work and
we want to take it a step further
agreeing with this work and building
upon this work which shows climate
change, we wanted to look at the
more broad understanding of Gaia through
the lenses of the free energy principle.
So instead of focusing on climate
change, which is very brilliantly done
by these researchers, we wanted to then
scale it up and apply the free energy
principle to understand the Gaia.
So then one can think of the internal
states as the biosphere geographical
processes and the external states as
everything that is beyond the system,
such as the outer atmosphere, Celicia
bodies and molten core. Then we can
think of sensory states as the external
environment impact such as the Earth
rotation, orbit, tides affected by the
sun, moon, planets, plate tectonics,
climate, weather influenced by solar
radiation, space weather, etc. So and
then we can think of the active states
as Earth's adaptability and adjusting
properties from external influence such
as gravitational force, altars orbits,
magnetic field interacts with solar
winds or emission of detectable
radiation influences distant objects.
That's a few examples. So then
I want to focus on the active states.
Active states then through this lens,
active states then embody its primary
mechanism for self regulation,
representing its efforts to remain
within the bounds required for ongoing
existence based on predictions about the
present and future states of the system.
For instance, the current levels of
greenhouse and albedo effects, soil PH
and the number of living organisms
reflect the predictive attempts of the
Gaia system to adapt to anticipated
effects of solar events, volcanic
eruptions, ocean salinity changes, and
other environmental factors in the
future. So it is in this context that
the role of life itself assumes a
paramount importance in the self
regulation of the biosphere. Because the
role of life itself, and particularly as
we are going to focus on next, the human
life, has a particular influence on
all of these sort of already natural
dynamics going on in the gaia.
This allows us, before we move into the
human effects, this allows us to make
one final point before we move there,
which is to address the criticism that
has been made in this paper by Vicente
Haja on the Markov blanket trick.
And what they have identified
is that a purported weakness of
the free energy principle what we say
is that a weakness of the free energy
principle that is identified in this
paper actually speaks in favor of its
application to the Gaia hypothesis. And
let me just try to explain that. So Raja
and colleagues, they rightly point out
that Markov Lincolns do not
automatically capture every relevant
property of biological systems,
relational properties such as
affordances. And by affordances they
mean what the environment offers, the
animal, what it provides, or furnishes,
either good or evil fall into this
bracket. So what they're saying is that
Markov blanket do not automatically
capture every relevant aspect of
biological system such as affordances,
right? And we want to point out
that however,
affordances correspond to Gaia as one
rung in the ladder of the Nested Marco
blankets within the system in question
at every level ranging up from,
say, cells, organs, animals,
ecosystems, solar systems, the whole
cosmos. And how is it that we think that
this particular framework that we bring
here does have or solve or address the
notion of affordances? Our solar system
is one that affords a living planet.
So the affordance available is an
environment. In an environment are not
determined solely by the physical
properties of the environment. And we
think that this is the point that we
would like to address in HaHa's paper,
is that the affordances are not
determined solely by the physical
properties of the environment, but also
by the organism's goals, abilities and
previous experiences and in this case,
of the sun. So what is meant here
is that the sun is what has the furnaces
for or what affords anything else to
happen on the planet at whatever each
scale, right? The physical properties of
the sun as well as the goals and
abilities of the organisms on earth
shape the affordances that the sun
provides. So it's a quite interesting
way of thinking that any affordance
whatsoever that we might think of that
we have as living systems, they are
afforded by the sun. So that's the idea.
Okay, so now having gone through how
the female G principle somewhat speaks
to and contributes to understanding the
Gaia hypotheses, then we want
to focus on how human behavior
has a profound effect on
the dynamics that already existing in
the natural world. Okay?
So according to the frequencies
principle, living beings have a natural
tendency to act upon their environment
to prevent dissipation of their
integrity. So that's what we do in order
to remain alive. There are therefore two
ways for a thing like us to minimize its
free energy and thereby maintain our own
integrity upon evidence. As we navigate
the world and gather and observe
evidence, we have two options.
One is to change the model. The other
one is to change the world by acting
upon it, like I just said before. So
then why is this relevant? Well, this is
relevant because there is the
possibility that in the ways in which
living systems and in this particular
case human beings interact and adapt to
the world, there is the possibility that
we see maladaptive behavior. And how
would that be? Well, if it is the case
that there is a rejection of the
information available so as to remove
the imperative for action or if it is
the case that possessing the information
available but we still remain or refrain
from taking action, then there seems to
be if the free energy principle is
correct if the free energy principle is
to be correct, that systems, living
beings tend to act upon the world in
order to remain alive and if it is
the case that one rejects that kind of
information and does not take action to
remain alive, such as the information of
the climate crisis, then we might be
looking at maladaptive behavior. So if
the free energy principle holds, then
the observed contradictory behavior is
a maladaptive state or should be seen as
a maladaptive state that arises from an
imbalance within the Markov blanket.
And how do we see this imbalance within
the Markov blanket? We see it to put it
in very, very simple terms, we see it as
an insulation of internal states that
are not being affected
by the information available outside of
the system. So the influences or the
interactions are occurring between
internal, active and sensory states.
And this is an imbalance that results in
an insulation or an echo chamber effect
in internal states that are impermeable
to the information from or potentially
existing in the external states that
demands action.
So then some food for thought.
What can we make of this? The free
energy principle? If we are to use the
free energy principle to model the
dynamics of the relationships between
humans and the environment then we think
that it is possible to see the current
lack of pro environmental behavior as a
pathology of the human species that must
receive treatment. We label this
condition as Biophilia Deficiency
Deficiency Syndrome. Biophilia
Deficiency Syndrome and
it is important for us to focus on that
to construct some validity. Is useful to
consider in this case other applications
of the free energy principle that may be
useful as an analogous case of pathology
mainly conducted in psychiatry and
neurology and in here and very short
because I don't have time. The idea is
to see it as a failure to assign the
right way or prediction to prediction
errors. So then the free energy
principle from this point of view this
is a persuasive pathology because doing
nothing is a base optimal response in
the face of pathological attention to
various sources of evidence. So evidence
is ignored. So concluding
and recapping according to the free
energy principle living systems possess
a biological encoded inclination to
interact with the environment in order
to survive and adapt to the environment.
And despite the climate change being a
pressing issue and the information being
available the evidence being available
proactive measures to reverse its
effects are not giving the priority they
deserve. This state of affairs seems
to show very clearly a divergence
from a natural inclination that we call
biophilia or that is existing in the
literature as biophilia. This
discrepancy between the expected and the
observed actions can be understood in
the framework of the free energy
principle or so we think. As an illness,
it implies that systems, including human
societies may form erroneous inferences
that prevent them from effectively
addressing the problem at hand. Now,
thinking about future directions and
this is my last slide current ecological
imbalances could be thought of as a
stuck state that require an active
disturbance to bring about some change.
A stuck state is a state that a system
is at a local minimum where the system
is at and won't get out of that state
unless it is disturbed. So that's the
principle in complex systems theory and
we think that that's how this particular
state should be looked at. But that's
for future research. And what we would
be calling is we would be calling for
amounts to the kind of homeostatic
awakening. So the sort of like getting
out of this stuck state would require
some kind of like omniostatic awakening
a deliberately induced disruptive shift
in the trajectory reflecting a
prioritization of the planetary
homeostasis over infinite growth or
staying in the same place. And yeah,
this is my last slide. Thank you so
much. I would like also to acknowledge
my co author Casper Montgomery. Thank
you so much for your attention.
Thank you. Well, a lot of ways to go.
I'll just ask one question just in the
years that you've been in the game how
do you see the active inference
ecosystem and the ways also that it's
being applied to ecosystems evolving,
like, over what timescales or in what
ways does that really present itself to
you? Slow,
sadly slow. I think there's a
lot of work that needs to be done.
We try to do this particular one here to
apply employ active inference to
the planet or the Earth as a living
system precisely to bring out or to
overcome. One is
to look at this problem of the climate
crisis as what we think it is, which is
more of a pathology. If the free energy
principle holds, then it seems that
there is maladaptive behavior of the
collective of the human species.
So I think that there's a lot of work
that can be done and that would very
much be useful in the climate crisis
in general. There is some other work
that came out more recently by Maxwell
and colleagues as well on the
ecosystems, which is really cool. And I
would also mention that one, and I
really hope that we can pursue this line
of research and employee active
inference in the free energy principle
to this particular case. One of
the things that really attracts me to
the free energy principle is the
capacity that it has to bring to the
forefront certain
laws of physics, but also the living
systems navigating and interacting with
their environments, which I find much
more appealing than any computational
framework per se. So that's what I find
that it's a very useful conceptual
toolkit that I think that I would really
like to see more applied in the future
for the climate crisis and the Earth.
Great. Well, thank you so much for
building on that line of work and for
sharing it with us tonight.
Thank you so much for having me. Till
next time. See you. Thank you.
Bye bye.
All right, well,
great talk by Ines!